As the Fast franchise hurtles
toward the finish line,
not every driver who starred in
the franchise has stayed in the
race. So what happened to the actress who
played Suki in "2 Fast 2 Furious," anyway?
Looking back on the "Fast & Furious" franchise, "2
Fast 2 Furious" set the tone for what was coming.
The Vin-Diesel-less sequel saw Brian taking
down an Argentinian drug lord with a racecar,
something that the modern "Fast" movies are
all too familiar with. It also introduced a few
franchise veterans, with Roman and Tej joining the
series. Suki, played by Devon Aoki, also played a
memorable role in "2 Fast 2 Furious," only to
disappear from the franchise without a trace.
Devon Aoki is best known as a model, finding
massive success in the industry before hitting
adulthood. However, in the early 2000s,
Aoki decided to test out the movie industry,
appearing in a few films before 2010.
Besides "2 Fast 2 Furious," she appeared
in movies like "Sin City," "D.E.B.S.," and the
infamous "Dead or Alive." However, in 2009,
she retired from acting to focus on raising
her kids, which might explain why she's never
returned to the "Fast & Furious" franchise. Since
then, she's only appeared in two documentaries,
with one of them, "I'll Sleep When I'm Dead,"
focusing on her half-brother DJ Steve Aoki.
In recent years, however, Aoki has
returned to the fashion industry,
which leads us to ask: could we see her return
to "Fast & Furious?" The franchise has brought
back old characters time and time again,
so it's arguably about time Suki returns.
"Alright, ladies. We're good. We're good."
"Fast X" is the beginning of the end for the "Fast
and Furious" franchise, so time's running out
for Aoki's Suki to return in the main series
if she ever does. The next installments will
likely celebrate the entire series, so the
more characters that come back, the better.
A spin-off may be the next best
option if fans don't get Suki
back in time for the franchise's
conclusion. In a 2022 interview,
Universal Pictures chairwoman Donna
Langley told Business Insider,
"I would love to see a female 'Fast.'
So would Vin [Diesel]. We have so many
great and amazing female characters in our
franchise and now there's the new addition of
Brie Larson to add to the incredible roster.
I would love to see us do a female 'Fast.'"
If that's the case, what better female
character to include than Suki? "2 Fast
2 Furious" introduces her as the leader
of an all-female street racing crew,
and she shows that she has what it takes to
race against anybody. If Universal plans to
do a female "Fast" movie, Suki could be in it,
assuming that Aoki is willing to return to the
screen. Pairing her with some of the other women
of the franchise sounds like a recipe for success.
It's not impossible. Devon Aoki appears to have
retired from regular acting for now, but she has
graced a few music videos since she stopped
appearing in movies and TV shows on a regular
basis. In 2013, she had a cameo in the video for
The Killers' single "Just Another Girl," which
shows her hanging out in a makeshift theater,
watching a black-and-white film on the screen.
Elsewhere, Aoki was one of a number of
celebrities who appeared in the video for
Fergie's track "M.I.L.F.$." In this one, the model
joined a slew of other celebrities to portray a
group of moms in a bubblegum-esque suburban
neighborhood. Aoki shows up in a few scenes,
rocking fancy outfits and hanging out
with Fergie's star-studded entourage.
The most recent music video Aoki starred in
was for Steve Aoki and BTS' "Waste It On Me"
collaboration. The video sees her out on
a date with a member of BTS, and she also
gets to mime some of the song's lyrics into
a microphone throughout the video. Of course,
a few music videos and documentary
appearances don't necessarily imply
that Aoki is dying to return to the
now-massive franchise she once made
a small appearance in. But if the franchise
does want to dig deep into its history again,
the records have shown that it's hard
to say no when Vin Diesel comes calling.
"Dom, don't get yourself killed,
okay? You're my favorite American."